It wasn't that long ago that little Prince George captured the world's attention with his arrival.
Now, the third heir to the throne is set to make his second official appearance at his christening.
The royal baby will be blessed in the Chapel Royal at St James's Palace tomorrow...
...and preparations are underway for his big day.
The Archbishop of Canterbury Justin Welby, who will baptize the prince,...
...has released a special message ahead of the event.
As a nation, we're celebrating the birth of someone who in due course will be the head of state.
That's extraordinary.
It gives you this sense of forward looking, of the forwardness of history,...
...as well as the backwardness of history and what a gift to have this new life and to look forward.
Taking a break from royal tradition, the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge...
...are having a private ceremony for their little one and are keen to keep the occasion as low-key as possible.
Even the guest list has not been released.
But Kensington Palace has said that close family members will attend.